hey before we get to today's video
here's a new show we're testing out it's
called time mission
imagine you're a time traveler being
sent on a mission to any point in
history past
present or future you might be sent to
stop the jfk assassination or
maybe even become the first human on the
moon anything is possible
and the more you watch the more we'll
make so check it out
attention human you are receiving an
interstellar
radio transmission and it could be
coming from one of the nearest
exoplanets proxima centauri b
what conditions make this planet a
candidate for alien life what types of
civilizations
could have flourished there and should
we expect them to be
knocking on earth's door any day now
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if there were an alien civilization on
proxima b at a distance of 4.2 light
years away
proxima centauri is one of the closest
stars to our sun
in 2016 a planet was discovered orbiting
in proxima centauri's
goldilocks zone that's where conditions
for
liquid water could exist meet
proxima b a planet that registers
at 0.87 on the earth
similarity index this scale measures how
similar a planet or moon is to earth and
anything above 0.8 is considered
earth-like
as another example mars has an esi of
0.64
in 2020 astronomers
recorded a mysterious radio signal
coming from
the direction of proxima centauri
could it be that an alien civilization
was attempting to contact
us though proxima b
is similar to earth life forms on this
alien planet would
likely develop very differently for
starters the planet
is about 20 times closer to its star
than
earth is to the sun and it only needs
11.2 days for
one full revolution that's a lot of new
year's celebrations
but still proxima b receives about the
same amount of solar energy as
earth and that's because proxima
centauri is an m-type
red dwarf star compared to our g-type
star
these stars are generally cooler in a
range of 2200 to
3200 degrees celsius but
there would be some extreme conditions
that an
alien civilization would have to adapt
to
these extraterrestrials would need to be
able to withstand
radiation and lots of it
the planet receives about 400 times more
x-rays than earth and dwarf stars like
proxima centauri
give rise to coronal mass ejections that
would blast the planet with lethal
radiation
without a protective atmosphere this
would be
deadly for any potential life forms
another challenge for a proxima b
civilization would be
tidal locking that's when a planet takes
the same amount of time to spin on its
axis as it does to orbit its star
imagine living where you permanently
face the scorching sun
while the other side of the earth is in
a constant state
of frozen darkness this is what life
would be like on this exoplanet
civilizations on proxima b would likely
develop
in the so-called terminator zones these
are the strips of twilight between the
day side
and the night side here winds would
carry warm air and
create life-supporting conditions and
aliens would build thermal reactors with
the mix of cool
and hot water to have that h2o always
available
but if civilizations appeared on either
of the sides of the terminator zone
they'd need to develop different
survival tactics
but collaboration and unity could allow
them to supply each other with
heat or ice effectively and
if a civilization developed on the light
side
would they even know that there were
other stars or objects in the universe
would they even think about other life
out in space
that brings us back to the radio signal
the breakthrough listen project recorded
in 2020
this signal occupied a very narrow band
of the radio spectrum at
982 megahertz this
is startling because it's a portion of
the spectrum
rarely used by human-made transmitters
researchers haven't ruled out the
possibility that these signals
originated on earth but there are many
unanswered questions
one thing they're sure of it didn't come
from
a natural world only manufactured or
alien-made technology seems to produce
signals like that so
if an advanced civilization was trying
to communicate with us from proxima b
what would their society be like
they could be a type 1 civilization like
us
and use the energy available from their
planet
like oil wind or geothermal power
or they could be a type 2 civilization
using energy on the scale of their
planetary system
that would mean they were thousands of
years more advanced than us
would they have developed complex
languages and live in cities
would they have democratic forms of
governance
or would they live under the rule of a
dictator
you must have so many questions for our
alien neighbors
and they would have so many questions
for you
or maybe they already know everything
unfortunately we likely won't be able to
visit them anytime soon
using current technologies it would
still take between
19 000 and 81 000 years
to reach them of course maybe they could
travel faster than the speed of light
and get here first and
who knows what would happen when they
finally get here
for all we know they could take over our
planet and
enslave us but
that's a story for another what if